joining me now Saul weisenberg former
deputy independent Council and former
assistant U.S attorney and David Schoen
former Trump impeachment lawyer Saul um
all of these new Revelations
um that we have just learned let's say
just in the last 72 hours
about Hunter Biden will this shame the
doj into actually bringing new charges
what's Your Gut tonight after all these
days that you've been on all week long
on the angle what's Your Gut
absolutely not I mean the fact that they
would even sanction
this attempted deceit on the court and
on the public tells you all you need to
know about that the fact that the
Attorney General uh Garland hasn't
gotten to the bottom of it and told the
public this is what really happened uh
all of the stonewalling that's going I
know I'm I'm totally skeptical of
anything resulting from it
well it seems
it seems falling back and we'll play the
sound bite on how much the bidens love
their son
okay they love their son that's all that
matters It's A Private Matter he needs
to be able to recover in peace the
process is under you know I guess it's
still under investigation so they're
going to fall back on that correct
I think that's right but I think frankly
Hunter Biden ought to be outraged that
his deal was broken they learned that
only yesterday in court his lawyers
seemed to be outraged when he said rip
it up I think they ought to move file a
motion for specific performance of the
plea agreement they understood they had
under Santa Bello and you know the judge
may not accept it but this is the only
way I think that we'll really get at
what promises were made to him it looks
like this broad immunity deal through
his diversion and if that's what he
thought he was entitled to I think he
ought to litigated
well we learned something really big
about Hunter Biden in court listen to
what he told the judge he said I started
a company in 2017 called Hudson West
your honor and my partner was associated
with the Chinese Energy company called
cefc the judge then said who is your
partner
um Hunter Biden answers I don't know how
to spell his name it's yeezon Ming the
chairman of that company well he made
over half million dollars through that
now what's notable here is that that
contradicts what his father told us back
in 2020. watch this my son has not made
money in terms of this thing about what
are you talking about China
well David what's your reaction here
well I I think that he has to read I'm
sorry we're on Saul I'm sorry yeah we're
on Saul sorry about that Saul go ahead
Saul what's your reaction there that
seems like a direct contradiction
well my reaction is what else is new I
mean uh virtually everything the
president has said about this about uh
the business dealings that his son had
in in China uh and and the Ukraine have
have been shown to be false and it just
doesn't seem to uh affect affect him
everybody just I guess looks at him as a
daughtering doting old father and uh and
they don't have any problem with it so
I'm not surprised at all
well let's move to this uh Trump issue
with Jack Smith the prosecutor releasing
a superseding indictment yesterday there
were three new charges against Trump
attempting to destroy alter mutilate or
conceal evidence uh also inducing
someone else to do so in a new count
under the Espionage Espionage Act
related to classified National document
security
um David let's go to you help us break
these down because
it looks like they have either on tape
or a witness
recounting conversations among Trump
employees and perhaps a notation that
the president spoke with one of those
employees about going in and allegedly
asking for servers to be deleted after
the government requested them right so a
couple of things with respect you know
the media and many in the media are
falling all over themselves that this is
a whole new chapter and they've really
got them now for two reasons mainly that
they've got this document about Iran
that was on the recorded call we don't
know that that's the case at all and in
any event his same defenses would apply
to that document if there were a
document but we don't know that that's
the document but then the it's there's
the bit about the deletion purported
deletion of the video that's classic you
know Tavares the witness says de
Oliveira told him that maybe NADA told
him that maybe Trump told him it's
hearsay on hearsay on hearsay there are
reasons that we have rules of evidence
reliability credibility the Integrity of
the process let's see how this plays out
frankly um I I think that the judge
ought to be quite angry they just had a
scheduling conference there was no
mention apparently of the superseding
indictment what happened did they have
this and hold it back or did they just
turn the screws to Tavares now remember
the government decides what the truth is
and if you're not cooperating with them
then you're not telling the truth from
the government's perspective at least a
prosecutor like this
it's all your take on that
that's an outstanding point you know
they had a scheduling conference and
recall that Jack Smith wanted the the
trial to start in December of this year
and said nothing about uh this the this
plans to do a superseding indictment or
to even present this evidence so uh it's
it's um David David's point is
outstanding and you know on the issue of
of Hunter Biden I don't think that the
opposition should give up I think by all
means there are people who need to be
hauled in front of the house and put
under oath and answered questions about
this because don't Hunter Biden the
hunter Biden the whole investigation the
whistleblowers and now what's happened
with this plea is is make no mistake
about it it's a terrible terrible
scandal
yeah and we got Leslie wolf Lisa Monaco
and a lot of other characters we need to
get to the bottom of it Saul and David
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else